[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
عشرت فلسطينيين واصابه اكثر من مئه اخرين
حالات بعضهم خطيره بالاضافه لاكثر من 250
حاله اختناق بالغاز الموسيلي للدموع خلال
اقتحام مدينه نابلس شماليه الضفه الغربيه
وقال مدير الاسعاف في نابلس ان قوات
الاحتلال منعت الاطقم الطبيه من الوصول
الى الاصابات وتقديم الاسعافات لها وافادت
مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه ثلاثه صحفيين اصيبوا
بالرصاص الحي خلال تقضيه تغطيتهم اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال مدينه نابلس هذا واندلعت
اشتباكات المسلحه بين مقاومين فلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال التي حاصرت منزلا بذريعه
اعتقال مطلوبين واعلنت سرايا القدس
التابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي استشهاده
قائد كتيبه نابلس محمد ابو بكر جنيدي خلال
المواجهات
معنى من نابلس مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديري جيفارا كيف يتطور
الوضع في نابلس
التطورات تاتي كل
نصف ساعه من قبل وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
في عمليه استغرقت اقل من اربع ساعات حتى
الان حصيله الشهداء عشره شهداء برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكثر من 100 جريح
وهناك اكثر من 200 وخمسين اصيبوا بحالات
اختناق هناك عداء عدد من الحالات الخطيره
لا زالت في غرف العمليات الجميع بانتظار
والخشيه بالطبع من ارتفاع عدد الشهداء
الان كما نرى وسيله لا زالت حاله من
التوتر تسود مدينه نابلس هنا نحن في وسط
المدينه كما نرى الحداد العام تجمع كبير
للفلسطينيين بالطبع استعدادا لتشجيع
الشهداء بعد حوالي الساعه كما تم الاتفاق
قبل قليل من قبل القوى الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
جميعا بان يتم الشيعه الشهداء اليوم ولا
يتم التاجيل الى يوم الغد بالطبع هذا
الاضراب والحداد هو ذات المشهد ايضا في
مدن عده من بينها في محافظه رام الله
والبيره بالطبع الوضع غايه في التوتر هناك
خشيه من قيام قوات الاحتلال هذا ما اكده
لنا البعض هنا من قيام قوات الاحتلال
بالدخول مجددا خاصه وان يتوقع كالعاده ان
يشارك عدد من المقاومين الفلسطينيين في
تشييع رفاقهم الذين سقطوا هذا اليوم في
هذه العمليه التي لا يصفونها الا بانها
ارهاب منظم حتى ما هذا ما اكده رئيس
الحكومه الفلسطينيه بانه ارهاب منظمه
تحاول من خلاله الحكومه الاسرائيليه تصدير
ازماتها الداخليه هنا الى الساحه في الضفه
الغربيه رغم كل التفاهمات السياسيه خلال
الاسبوع الماضي بوقف اجتياحات
الغربيه ولكن ايضا نذكر التطورات
الميدانيه وفق بيان للجيش الاسرائيلي فانه
يقول انه من بين من قتلهم هنا في نابلس
ثلاثه يصفهم بالطبع بالمخربين هم مقاومون
فلسطينيون ثلاثه مقاومين سقطوا اثنان في
المنزل الذي كان محاصر في داخل البلده
القديمه والثالث كان في الخارج لانه هنا
هذه المنطقه كلها كانت وكانها اشبه بساحه
حرب مواجهات عنيفه سواء
بالسلاح بين مقومين فلسطيني مسلحين وجنود
الاحتلال او بين شبان يلقون الحجاره ولكن
ما حدث في داخل البلده القديمه ان قوات
الاحتلال باضروعها المختلفه حاصرت منزل
كان يتحسن به مقاومان فلسطينيان واحدهما
وهو محمد حسام سليم قام بتسجيل الوص صوتيه
اكد انه لن يقوم بتسليم انفسنا هما هو
ومحمد
الجنيدي وانهم يطالبون الفلسطينيين من
خلال هذه الوصيه بمواصله النضال ايضا قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي رفعت حاله التاهب
القصوى بعد البيان الذي صدر من عده فصائل
فلسطينيه واخرها كان من الناطق باسم كتائب
القسام ابو عبيده الذي قال في بيان مقتضب
بان
الجميع ينظر الى الضفه الغربيه وبان الصبر
المقاومه اخذ بالنفاذ وايضا التهديد من
قبل سرايا القدس الجناح المسلح لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وايضا من باقي الفصائل من
حركات فتح الجبهه الشعبيه الجبهه
الديمقراطيه وغيرها من الفصائل وايضا كانت
كتيبه عرين الاسود اكدت انها لن تتوقف في
مقاومه الاحتلال ستواصل
وبالطبع يعني ما حدث لا يصفه الفلسطينيون
باختلاف اطيافهم الا بانهم مجزره نحن
نتحدث عن عشره شهداء
اكثر من 100 جريح كلهم في المستشفيات
التوقعات ان لا يهدا الوضع الميداني ان
يكون من بين الشهداء شهيد يزيد عمره عن 72
عاما وشهيد اخر يبلغ من العمر 61 عاما
منعت الطواقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه من الوصول
الى هذين الموسينين الاهالي هنا من راوا
هذين الرجلين على الارض
يعني الدم مدرج على الارض اكدوا لنا بان
الطواقم الطبيه كان يطلق عليها النار
مباشره الرصاص الحي لمنع الطواقم الطبيه
من الوصول الى الجرح وهذا يمكن ما قد رفع
وفق الطواقم الطبيه عدد الشهداء في هذا
اليوم ايضا كان هناك استهداف مباشر لل
الصحفيه وكما ذكرت وسيله كان هناك على
الاقل ثلاثه صحفيين تم استهدافهم بالرصاص
الحي بشكل مباشر غير الصحفيين بالطبع
الذين اختنقوا بشكل كبير جدا من قنابل
الغاز التي كانت تطلق بشكل عشوائي اذا كما
ذكرت لك وسيله الوضع غايه في التوتر هنا
في نابلس ولكن ايضا في مناطق عده في الضفه
الغربيه تم الدعوه يوم غد لاضراب شامل
وحداد في عده مدن بلدات ولكن يبدو ان
الاضراب والحداد بدا في عده مناطق منذ
اليوم ومنذ يعني وما بدء ارتفاع عدد
الشهداء الفلسطينيين هنا يقولون ليس
المشكله في عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيون لم
يعودوا مجرد ارقام 61 شهيدا سقطوا برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه العاب
اي في اقل من شهرين هذا عدد يوازي يعني
على الاقل من العام الماضي الذي وصفه
الفلسطينيون والمؤسسات الدوليه من بينها
الاتحاد الاوروبي بانه كان الاكثر دمويه
منذ عام 2005 ففي شهرين ماذا يمكن ان يدلل
ذلك خاصه وانه في هذا اليوم كل التصريحات
السياسيه من المسؤولين وايضا الوفد
الاتحاد الاوروبي يندد بما يحدث اشكرك
جزيل الشكر البديري من نابلس